Razors marketing its latest 14-inch
blade gaming laptop as powerful portable
perfect
after going hands-on with it over the
past few days our responses are kind of
yes and definitely no razors laptop will
appeal to users who want a small sexy
notebook but it makes glaring
compromises in the name of portability
welcome to game tech where we put gaming
hardware through their paces razors 2017
blade is very thin at 0.7 inches its
unibody aluminum chassis feels
exceptionally well made it's small frame
and 4.1 pound weight it get extremely
portable overall the matte black laptop
looks sleek while razor sells a fork a
variant our unit came with a 1080p panel
it's a really good one though and offers
a bright 350 net IPS solution that
offers vivid accurate colors with wide
viewing angles the blade has one of the
best keyboards we've seen in a laptop
all it may not be mechanical it does
feel tactile and clicky the keys are
also individually backlit and support
razor's chroma lighting software that
provides up to sixteen point eight
million colors there are also different
color options that pulsate do the wave
and more there are two speakers on both
sides of the keyboard that sound clear
and crisp they're also relatively
powerful despite the laptops small size
the trackpad beneath the keyboard also
works well and we like the fact that it
has discreet left and right click
buttons one area where the laptop is
lacking is in ports the blade offers an
HDMI port 3 USB 3.0 ports a hybrid
analog headphone jack and a Thunderbolt
3 connection we don't like how the blade
emits an SD card slot and Ethernet port
though the latter is crucial for any
serious gaming laptop beneath the
chassis the Razer Blade is equipped with
an Intel Core i7 7700 HQ quad-core CPU
it's supplemented with 16 gigabytes of
ddr4 ram for its graphics card its own
width Nvidia's GeForce GTX 1060 which
pairs sensibly well with the plates
1080p monitor those specs are good
enough to make it be already where our
specs fall extremely short is in the
storage department while there are 512
gigabyte and 1 terabyte versions that
retail for twenty one hundred and twenty
five hundred dollars respectively our
$1,900 unit simply came with a 256
gigabyte SSD that's right there's no
hard drive for mass storage here
considering there are modern games like
call duty infinite warfare
that need over 100 gigabytes of space a
256 gigabyte solution feels really out
of place for a gaming laptop in 2017
frankly a 256 gigabyte only SKU
shouldn't exist in this day and age we
may be slightly more forgiving here if
it came with an ultra-fast nvme SSD but
it doesn't which makes this aspect
pretty inexcusable to give you a point
of comparison for performance we've
benchmarked the razorblade against the
origin pc evil 15s we reviewed back in
May while that laptop is slightly bigger
with its 15.6 inch frame both notebooks
for the same CPU GPU and ram we ran a
bunch of games maxed out at 1080p to
really stress test the laptops while
both notebooks are similarly SPECT
razors laptop is slightly slower than
origin TC solution this is most likely
due to the blades smaller size still the
blades should be able to muster smooth
playable framerates or graphically
demanding games like rise of the Tomb
Raider max down with the exception of
the most grueling games like Deus Ex
mankind divided the system's pcie-based
SSD will allow you to install and load
games quickly with read and write speeds
of 1640 and 310 megabytes per second
respectively though it's still
significantly slower than origin pcs
superior and vme solution when we ran
the laptop through our grueling battery
test it lasted exactly 70 minutes well
that's not the worst we've seen you'll
most likely want to carry the charger
with you the Razer Blade laptop gets
pretty warm perhaps more annoying than
the heat however is the notebooks fan
noise it gets really loud when you're
gaming the laptop can also get loud just
sitting in the OS in terms of form
factor and build quality the Razer Blade
really kills it unfortunately its felt
design makes sacrifices when it comes to
storage ports and thermals if all you
play is one or two games and don't care
about those shortcomings you should keep
the razor blade in mind to everyone else
it's one of the nicest devices that we
can't recommend for the full in-depth
written breakdown head on over to
GameSpot comm and after that check out
our review of the Origin PC evil 15s if
you liked this video give it a thumbs up
and subscribe for more thanks for
watching